Our expert interview today will be with Dr. John Allen who will share his
perspective on emotion elicitation.
Dr. Allen received his phd from the University of Minnesota and is currently a
distinguished professor of psychology,
cognitive science and neuroscience at the University of Arizona.
Dr. Allen is a renowned expert in emotional elicitation and he's co edited a
handbook on this very topic.
He's well known for research involving psychophysiological tools to understand
the origin and treatment of mood and anxiety disorders.
He's published over 120 scientific papers,
received numerous grants and awards for his research that include the early
career award from the Society for psychophysiological research and importantly
has a deeply embedded passion for teaching.
This has been reflected in the graduate college and Professional Education,
teaching and mentoring award and designation as a university distinguished
professor and in addition to his expertise in emotion and emotional visitation,
he's also an avid mountain biker and Munis cyclist.
So I'd like to welcome Dr. John Allen who will be speaking with today on
emotional elicitation.
So I'd like to begin with what first got you interested in this study of
emotion.
So could you tell us a bit about what first sparked your interest in the field?
Sure.
You know,
as far back as I can remember,
I was interested in people's emotions.
Uh,
and one of the things I remember thinking often as a,
you know,
an adolescent was I'd watch people make decisions that they seem to have reasons
for that didn't correspond to what I saw the reasons were for the decision they
made.
You know,
in my mind I thought this looks like an emotional decision to me.
And they'd come up with all kinds of reasons for the reasons that they thought
that they did it.
And it kind of got me interested in how decision making is driven in large part
by emotion and emotions that we may or may not be aware of.
And you may or may not be aware of their influence on the kinds of decisions
that we make.
And so when I was in college,
I took a few courses on emotion.
At this point I didn't know that this would be a field of study for me.
It's just something of interest.
And a,
the first course was of course on the philosophy of emotions where I guess
ironically we spend a lot of time thinking about emotions.
And then I took a course from a Howard Leventhal.
Uh,
it was a course on the psychology of emotion,
you know,
a large 300 or 400 level course.
It was amazing that it was offered.
And he would walk through study after study on professor specters of emotion.
And then finally I was fortunate that while at the University of Wisconsin
Madison,
um,
to take my first psychophysiology course from Richie Davidson who had just
arrived.
And so those three courses,
you know,
really got me interested in emotion and multiple perspectives on emotion.
And you know,
I realize this was a topic,
it was important.
It's a topic that was complex and it was a topic that was far from fully
understood.
And so aside from the intrinsic interest that's certainly suggested,
that kind of topic that might lead to job security.
Excellent.
And I mean,
since then,
you've just seen so much research in the field of emotion.
So I'd love to just ask you a few questions now about your research.
Um,
so I mean,
you've co-edited one of the most widely read handbooks in our field,
the handbook of emotional incitation.
So I'd love to hear in your opinion,
what you think are some of the most effective or powerful tools were really
triggering these,
you know,
really a fascinating and intense feelings of emotion that we experience.
Sure.
Well,
there are a lot of good elicitation techniques for use in the laboratory and
studies of emotion.
And I think those that are the most potent are those that involve some form of
social interactions.
I think they have the greatest resemblance to the majority of our real world
emotional experiences.
But I think really the big challenge is trying to increase the intensity and the
realism and the ecological validity of the elicitation of emotion.
So,
you know,
I think about even the best that we do in the laboratory,
it really doesn't compare to what we see.
You know,
just quotidian life we have in instances of road rage and you know,
um,
romantic jealousy,
interpersonal conflict or even just the kind of intense emotion you see at a
major sporting event.
Um,
these are the kinds of emotions that I really think,
you know,
we need to try to study when possible and it's so far,
that's difficult to do in the laboratory,
but clearly those kinds of manipulations that involve interactions with other
people or those,
I think they get the closest to that.
Um,
you know,
this kind of,
as I was thinking about this,
um,
it leads me to a provocative and maybe a hyperbolic proposition that is what we
really study in the laboratory is mild motion or we studied the inhibition of a
regulation of anything that gets a little stronger than mild emotion.
And so,
you know,
I'm surely overstating the case,
but I think the disentangling,
whether we're looking at the experience of emotion or are we looking at the
regulation of that experience of emotion is very difficult.
Right?
Are we looking at emotion or regulation or inhibition of emotion?
And that's probably surprisingly
tricky.
It sounds like that might be an important next step is to really try to develop
tools that can elicit and try to disentangle these two constructs
an important step.
Yes,
definitely.
And then there's a large re,
you know,
there's a large program of research going on on emotion regulation.
Um,
but that doesn't really get at this question either.
Yeah.
So what do you see then as some of the critical next steps and we think about
developing tools for emotional elicitation going forward?
Um,
you know,
I think probably,
uh,
this is going to be to increase,
increase the realism that we have and move this into real world context.
Yeah.
So kind of increasing ecological validity using like the social dynamic tasks
you're talking about interacting with another person,
maybe getting into the car when someone's experiencing road.
Yeah.
With the,
with the increased availability of ambulatory tools psychophysiological or
otherwise.
I think a lot of this would,
you know,
be within our grasp within a few years.
So there's been a lot of work improving ambulatory psychophysiological
monitoring systems,
for example,
um,
other forms of ambulatory assessment.
There's now a society for ambulatory assessment that involves psychophysiology
and,
and other kinds of methods.
Um,
you know,
in this,
in this domain.
And I'd like to also give a shout out to Scott Mccain.
He's got something that he calls Moby the modal mobile brain body imaging.
And although he doesn't study emotion,
um,
he has a system where people can walk around,
he can record 64 or 128 channels of EEG while they freely Roman environment.
And you can keep track of what they're looking at,
where,
how they're moving,
where they are,
what's going on in the scene.
And all of the data stream is mark.
Wow,
that's fascinating.
And so thinking more about emotional citation tools,
I mean,
you've specialized in using really complex and very cool psychophysiological
tools in studying emotion.
So what would your thoughts be on some of the most powerful or provocative tools
you've used in your own research?
Well,
you know what?
Psychophysiological research,
a lot of this depends on tight temporal control over the stimuli.
And so there's this tension between,
on the one hand,
um,
the need for such experimental control.
And on the other hand presenting the kind of complex,
intense emotional visitors' that probably unfold over time.
Um,
so if we try to focus on more discreet elicits of emotion,
I think films can really serve that purpose pretty well.
It's a,
so that's something which people are generally familiar.
Um,
it's possible to generate some pretty intense emotion,
but we're still talking about a timescale of course that spans seconds to
minutes.
So if we're looking for really discreet responses to kind of a transient
effective response,
then you know,
something like international ethic picture series,
the picture system,
the I ops is certainly well suited it's industry standard.
Um,
but you know,
if I were on the motion picture rating committee,
I'd give the I ops a PG 13 and I'd really like to see us come out with an r
rated or an NC 17 rated version of the iops.
And we'd have to be thoughtful and sensitive about the people to whom we expose
to those stimuli.
But you know,
I certainly think that the average college student has seen things that make the
iops seem rather tame.
Um,
in another way you can get around the timing issue and get back to having a
potent emotional elicit her is to use some kind of complex and realistic
emotional elicitations strategy that then creates an effect of state that
endorsed for some time.
And then you can assess what you're interested in during that time interval,
um,
or when you know,
when the person is or is not experiencing emotions.
So for example,
we've used as social evaluative threat manipulation.
Um,
in this kind of manipulation,
people experience an uncontrollable situation,
the experiment or provides a vert feedback that there's failure going on.
Um,
we leave the door to the sacrifice chamber open,
we sit there with our white coats.
It's a little bit like a tree or experience,
but instead them giving a speech,
they're performing the task on the computer.
And we've done this in the context of basic performance monitoring tasks and
reinforcement learning tasks and looking how emotional stress impacts peoples
ability to monitor their own performance and make decisions.
Um,
and another example of that,
of creating an effective state they might endure for awhile,
um,
I think is really nicely exemplified by work that Eddie Harmon Jones does.
So he,
and one of his paradigmatic ways,
he makes people angry.
And I have to say that he's really good at making people angry in the
laboratory.
So he has like a good experimental confederate come in and the confederate says
something that's insulting to the subject about some aspect of their performance
or their beliefs.
And then you assess this physiology and the interval that follows during which
the person is presumably continuing to feel something
kind of emotion.
Fantastic.
So,
I mean,
I'm thinking a bit too about your own work here,
where you really use these complex psychophysical yeah.